here are some words you're probably
using wrong oral of or relating to the
ears or hearing oral spoken of or
relating to the mouth Beyonce's oral
powers forced everyone with any oral
sense to bow down ascend to move upward
ascent the expression of approval or
agreement Sharon should have gotten her
neighbor's assent before she ascended
their roof to practice parkour
prescribed to recommend a substance or
action as something beneficial
prescribed to ban or prohibit something
once Martha was prescribed xanax
she knew operating heavy machinery would
be prescribed restful having a quiet and
soothing quality restive feeling bored
or impatient Jessica's parents were
growing restive while she became more
restful with being unemployed and living
at home in genuine
innocent and unsuspecting ingenious
clever original and inventive Maria may
be in genuine could deny her plan to dog
nap the Queen's corgis was ingenious
discreet careful in one speech or
actions discrete individually separate
and distinct Stefanie is proud to have
many discreet hobbies but she is very
discreet about her Fight Club flammable
easily set on fire inflammable easily
set on fire
well that's just confusing it goes to
show you that sometimes the world
doesn't make sense in these rules and
constructions are the only things that
make you feel like you're a part of
something larger that you understand and
without them the universe would just
look like a void we were never meant to
exist in